what's up everyone we are back at the
blockchain economic forum we are now
three stones hey thanks for coming out
of the show thank you again okay yes
Rhys is man I should know which episode
number somewhere around 20 Rhys is about
episode number 20 if you want to go and
check out that episode that we did in
the studio together it's a fantastic
episode and we did talk about blockchain
in that episode we also talked about
myriad of other things including
consciousness and biology and a bunch of
other things and now we're at the
blockchain economic forum where you
spoke you also spoke at Stanford and
Harvard last like two days so you've
been doing a little bit of traveling but
it's really important I think to get
rees-jones this perspective on what's
going on with decentralization and give
us your like high-level take on what's
going on we'd love to learn well I think
in a simple level blockchains a new
Internet Protocol that like internet
protocols that are come before I have
sort of growing pains and and and
standardization adoption process and
what is interesting is is blockchain
brings a few things to the internet that
weren't normally part of the internet
before most notably identity and trust
and with identity and Trust you can do
money and with those two you can and the
consensus algorithms you can have a
objective measure of the truth that at
least the truth is that people agreed on
it at the time that it was recorded and
the truth could be wrong but at least
it's what people agreed on at the time
which is probably better what they might
agree on in the future and so by having
identity trust money and truth it
creates a platform for doing new kinds
of applications that haven't really been
built before or widely deployed on the
Internet and so that's a really
opportunistic time sort of like the
beginning of the web protocol or even
file transfer protocol or mail protocols
these things that have turned into such
an important part of life that at the
beginning they were just simple
protocols
so the key words right there
identity trust consensus truth truth and
money and money yes so with identity
trust truth consensus we can transact
things like money transact things like
voting or biometrics give access control
to certain things so this is kind of the
uuu compared it to the Internet that's
part of the internet that blockchain is
built on top of Internet and they're not
protocols so it's it's like a new
enhancement to the Internet mmm and just
like the the web protocol wasn't part of
the Internet to begin with and it came
actually quite a bit later and it
created a new kind of interface a new
kind of user experience a new kind of
applications were things like Facebook
and YouTube and stuff are coming right
out of that and and if you evolve since
then but it's it was the internet was a
very different place before that and and
so with blockchain adding to that it
adds another several dimensions all at
once that like the initial obvious
applications or money or things like
Bitcoin which is a currency that runs on
top of a blockchain and so that's
something that is an obvious application
that has taken off but there's many more
to come that you know having to do with
ownership and and things that happen
over time and things that exchange from
one person to another that aren't
necessarily money but are things like
the chain of custody of who of the the
provenance of something like food or
pharmaceuticals like where was this
grown and when and and then how what
truck did it go on and how was it
processed and how was it how long was it
stored and safely and traceability yeah
and and could it have been infected with
something along the way
so you you can see that not just you
yourself but everybody involved can see
it in
public blockchain so it's sort of like
public record that is updated as things
happen with everybody agreeing on it on
the terms so it's almost better than an
audit it's actually the agreed upon
truth of something that can't be
modified it's immutable and that once
it's recorded in the record the the
records build upon themselves and so the
historical things can't be changed
without everybody being able to see the
change so you could say well this is
actually what it should have been but
what it was at the time that people
agreed on is different and and we've
changed our opinion now but all of that
is is publicly available for everybody
involved and it's not destroyed on one
computer it's stored in a distributed
way across thousands of computers over
the internet so if one of them fails or
if one of them gets compromised the
others will show that that that's a
problem one as opposed to the record is
disappearing as it might happen you know
centralized things yeah um a couple
things to play off of that one of the
main things that I think you said was uh
about the augmentation to the Internet
this is a built with the internet layer
this is building an identity trust
consensus truth and then enabling us to
do things like move money and so this is
an augmentation to the Internet it's an
enhancement we're moving into a new era
and there are certain weaknesses there
are certain vulnerabilities to this and
I think we're going to get past these
weaknesses and vulnerabilities and
there's gonna be something
it's especially crazier and better that
gets augmented on top of this so maybe
some of these things that we want to ask
you about that one of the things being
is as the amount of ownership of the
nodes is concentrated to a small amount
of people this the scare of them being
able to rewrite what's on the chain to
their advantage can you tell us about so
what you're talking about it is mining
nodes that replicate the data record of
the blockchain so in the
in the case of bitcoins blockchain I
should say there are several different
kinds of block chains in Bitcoin is just
one of that it uses a proof-of-work
mechanism to evaluate whether the
consents the the transaction is valid
and many different people or different
machines do the mining which is
calculating an amount of work that and
the first machine to calculate the the
next block to write correctly gets paid
and the others who came in second and
third and so forth at least can read a
consensus of what was happening so
there's a bit of a race with a little
bit of a luck formula put in to to write
each block and any of the thousands of
machines that are doing that race partly
by luck can be the one that that is
first and the others bring up the
consensus and that and then this is done
for every single block and there are
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
machines that are doing this mining and
because of the luck factor there isn't
any particular entity that can dominate
that process and so if you can get a
hundred thousand chances so if you have
a hundred thousand of those machines
yourself right and so one of the things
that protects bitcoins blockchain is
that it takes a lot of compute power to
calculate this block and that takes a
lot of electricity and few people have
that amount of compute power and fewer
still have that amount of electricity so
if there it's hard enough just to do the
correct thing and validate the correct
transaction but if you're trying to
manipulate the the database of the
blockchain database you would not only
have to do that faster than all the
other computers and be lucky to get the
luck one to record the data that you
wanted to do differently but you're also
replicating the past block transactions
and so there would be kind of a record
that you have to reproduce that takes a
lot of energy and a lot of compute power
and so it's so much work to just do it
correctly it's even more work to hack it
or to do it try and manipulate it in
some way
so that's something that is perhaps
protected Bitcoin from hacker
manipulation just because of the way the
algorithm and and this this consensus
effect and then this blockchain
replicating effect all pieced together
that and even if you were to hack it on
one node the other nodes who were
calculating it also might get a
different result and so the consensus
wouldn't agree and so the whole system
would re-evaluate as to what what's
changed or what's been going on but a
potential whole node take over all the
node take over to rewrite there's many
of these scenarios and I think it's very
interesting to see what exactly is going
to be the solution to that that that
issue there's a concept called 51%
takeover where you would have to get
artificial consensus of apparently 51%
of the nodes participating that moment
or that day and and that would take any
norm right now the the bitcoins
blockchain consumes a material
percentage of the Toba world's
electricity and something around 5% or
variable but it's a and it's not the
sort of thing that even a nation-state
could easily spend to to try and pervert
the system now alright how about we ask
you this question which is what should
not be decentralized
well that so very few things are
decentralized one of the talks I gave
here is something that is decentralized
is biology and genetics and that biology
is fully distributed to decentralize
there isn't a central government of
genetics or a central bank of genetics
and and the transactions happen between
meeting individuals and they're not
centralized and so in that sense it's
it's quite a bit like blockchain and
it's decentralized borderless nature of
it and so there are some things where if
something is very fast and
state-dependent like that you would want
a central point that is managing the
state for example of airline airplane
engines or
or certain kinds of reactions that are
you know millisecond nanosecond
femtosecond dependent on on the sequence
of events happening that's something
that is best done in a centralized way
because you can guarantee the state of
the system and the you know first-in
first-out type of sequences so if you're
trying to do something that is is very
fragile sensitive to time a centralized
system is probably the best choice and
and a distributed decentralized system
can be better for stability like the
internet also is decentralized and
distributed and so that if one part of
it breaks there are paths around the
broken part however that it invokes a
certain kind of latency or certain kind
of delay so things that are very fast or
very time-dependent you can't be so
precisely sure how long something is
going to take going through the internet
or going through a a blockchain type of
transaction where so that that's one
kind of Klu of something perhaps better
in a centralized way however you can
build hybrids of things where maybe the
record of what happened is decentralized
where when it's happening it's
centralized yeah that hybrid is cool too
that was a good answer I'm really trying
to find the the the interesting examples
where centralization actually might be
better it's just an interesting like
blacksheep question as everybody's
screaming decentralization what could
centralization possibly be good for okay
how about we ask you what are you most
looking forward to with blockchain
technology but specifically in
socioeconomic status so for low SES
middle SES high SES well one big problem
in the world is there's billions of
people who have no identity no passport
no papers no name identity that can be
verified by a government or anyone and
so that really limits people's life they
can't own anything because they don't
have an identity who would own it and
they can't easily move from place to
place
because nobody knows who they are even
if they're standing in front of you and
and and there's some dangerous for when
somebody's trying to hurt them to get
their possession we're trying to help
them like say I'll give you a house but
who are you who are you yeah and so it's
so blockchain is a way that that
people's identity can be put into the
internet basically you know in an
immutable way that once somebody is
entered into the system their identity
is is securely registered and and that
allows services and and and capabilities
like ownership and and right to do
things into a data system that can be
used and distributed where they can't
easily be destroyed by a government or
some other negative factor so the that
that's a big thing and that has a dark
side to it where if you put in that
entity you know information about the
person that like their medical history
for example that is something that can
be used for them and can be used against
them where there's a long history of
humanity trying to selectively eliminate
categories of people based on criterion
and so if the criterion including their
medical record is is in a blockchain
type of database that that information
can be used both for good and for bad
and so the bad might be say you know
banning certain groups from from passing
a border or killing people because of
some characteristic and so that's that's
the bad side where if if there's a
certain like exposure to an infection if
you have a database of that you know
exactly who to go and and you know solve
that right away what about fur middle
SES and high SES
so so for people once they have identity
and some amount of money and an
ownership of things then the it's a it's
a more fish
Way or decentralized isn't necessarily
the most energy and cost efficient but
it is human efficient where you can do
banking and financial transactions and
other things in many cases without
significant cost so if you're moving
money between people around the world or
if you're moving yourself around the
world it's doing that with a
distributive blockchain type of
record-keeping is more efficient than
having a lot of entities in the middle
be they governments or banks or
accounting or other things that may have
good intentions but they at least add a
delay and they had cost and they may add
other kinds of problems of not a
transparent transaction as you would
have on a on a public watching and
that's definitely a good progression
from the basic identity and ownership
needs of Louis yes to the middle middle
SES of transactions of money and
ownership in that sense and then also
then the the higher end of things which
we've heard of now a couple times is all
of these more expensive more lavish
things around the world to make sure
that the diamonds are coming from this
place or that the one you know every
only every five of these have been
painted and you owned one of them and so
there's these ways for it to be
applicable for highest yes as well so
how about just a quick end here
regarding this shift there is a lot of
there's a lot of people in the Bay Area
that are pushing for the shift whereas
like if you go to even 200 miles away in
central California you walk over you're
like flock chain and they're like what's
black chain so there's currently just
push to like get it out to more people
in the world and it seems that seems to
be a very good thing that's going on
with that push whereas here it seems
like everybody knows about it's kind of
interesting that those dynamics exist
with information what is the way that
govern
and humans and private industry science
industry how are the what what how are
we gonna actually be able to interact
with this data with each other through
the decentralized technology especially
with governments that are centralized
entities all of a sudden now with this
massive decentralization push well so
that's a you can look back at how the
resistance to adoption of the internet
happened in in the early days where you
know doing financial transactions on the
internet whether by credit card or other
means was resisted for a long time
especially by institutions that they
didn't want to allow transactions coming
on what was a paper record type system
or a non-public communication system
that there was a fear a risk of putting
things like confidential transactions on
the internet because they might not get
there they might be hacked they're
unpredictable delivery time there's a
lot of things that were resisted and and
so for example things like home banking
took a while before you could even do
that over the public Internet and then
even longer before bank to bank
transactions would would be approved for
going over the internet plumbing and so
that kind of thing it took a decade
really to to be kind of embraced and so
blockchain is likely to be similar where
there are certain you know libertarian
individual kind of things that people
are are you know happy to put at risk
through the public blockchain while
we're in this period where people are
still uncertain about how reliable it is
how secure it is how dependable you know
the transactions are that kind of thing
and and there's certainly resistance to
doing anything different and for things
like banking or securities or money that
have been done a certain way for
hundreds of years to change that not
only are
afraid of change but there's a lot of
intermediary parties their whole
lifestyle in their institution there are
are you know predicated around things
being done a certain way and if it
becomes evident that you can go around
that but they resist that at the
government level at the business level
at the just personal level and so it's
gonna take some time for these things to
you know be widely adapted just thinking
about governments and other centralized
entities like banks especially as well
just slow slowly loosening the grip that
they've had is that's kind of what it
would be like over the next day but at
the same time banks are accountable for
the integrity of transactions like if
something goes wrong though they'll pay
for it and and governments are there
trying to protect the citizenry and you
know and they say well we don't want
widows and orphans and grandmas and
investing in this risky thing because
they might lose all their money and
that's a noble good thing for society
that that to not you know put at risk
people who may not understand what
they're doing yes
now the counter-argument for that is you
know the you know a grandma who's
investing their aetherium ERC 20 into an
IC o---- token offering by a
cryptographic you know funds transferred
I want to be this round it's not an
unsophisticated investor and so the the
you know the average person is not even
easily able to invest in some of these
more risky things like icos and and of
course there's things in between like
coinbase which is easy to sign up with a
credit card and and you can buy some
Bitcoin or whatnot now the banks are
saying well we won't let our credit
cards be used for that because we've
already had experience with people
buying a lot of Bitcoin on the credit
card the Bitcoin going down and now they
can't pay their credit card bill and so
the banks don't like that the government
doesn't like that and the people who
can't pay their bill don't like that you
know so the government does do good
things
oh they absolutely do yeah yeah this is
one of the things that I think many
people don't really respect that the
government does
is the protection the Department of
Defense the safety that were making sure
that there are no national crises that
are going on in our homeland
domestically sure and and so one of the
things that's come up in the last six
months or so with these initial coin
offerings and investment things in in
became Bitcoin and and new token types
is a requirement from the government
that something called kyc which is know
your customer meaning you know is this
money coming from a terrorist group in
some country that we don't know or is it
coming from somebody that we can
validate is a valid person the identity
if you will and then the other is the
anti money laundering things which is is
the source of that money for that person
legal or illegal and so the that if so
making it difficult for stolen money to
be changed into a different form with
the anti money laundering or for you
know risky citizens to be or risky
people to be doing transactions that
might be for nefarious purposes
and this is not a perfect system like
for example real estate is exempt from
anti money laundering
types of record-keeping where you know
people can steal some money in some
country and buy a condo somewhere else
and not be tracked that way so these
rules of regulatory compliance and
government oversight aren't universally
applied in all transactions which
clearly leads to problems around the
world yeah there seems to be a push for
collective fabric of decentralization as
well to prevent going over borders and
doing things like using laundered money
to purchase proper human trafficking
really graphic drug sales or weapons
sales terrorism there's a lot of bad
things that happen in the world and so
having some controls built into the
technology and regulation to manage that
is a good thing whose hands - that gun
swap and all these other types of
conversational points that hopefully
will
continue unpacking more over the next
2018 s been a massive massive hype with
technology and a lot of initial
execution and I still think 2019 it's
gonna be quantum computing I'm serious
it'll be a little bit of a hype on that
as well
but I think people will be riding the
blockchain for a while Reese got
anything upcoming interesting that you
want to plug black jeans more blockchain
stuff coming up for Reese will have
Reese's links in the bio to go check him
out Reese thank you again for coming on
in the show the blockchain economic
forum it's always a pleasure hearing
from you you know learning from you
thank you everyone if you had a good
time definitely give us a comment below
with your thoughts go share it with this
content with two other people talk to
them about it have them talk to two
people about it and just like that will
spread it also subscribe and join us on
patreon we're trying to sustain this
project continue scaling and impacting
more people growing it to the sports
stadiums you know it so thank you very
much for tuning in much love thanks
everyone
bye-bye